[Music]
right now but I want the co-instructors
for the Frankie seminar my place and
cast hazel car be such a tremendous -
Gary so
we have with us today professor
underfunding from hearing to be able to
ask him questions to have the seminar
asking questions for hours this
afternoon so we continue our discussion
so professor Bombay is Arts and Sciences
distinguished professor and director
interdisciplinary workshop on colonial
and postcolonial studies at Emory
University he's trained of leadership EE
and watch the University and has had
tenured appointments at many
universities around the world in India
the UK Europe for the US and Japan as
well he is of course as many of you know
a founding member and leading theorist
of the supportive studies project and in
part as part of that project he's
written extensively on colonial and
postcolonial South Asia on nationalism
and minorities civil rights and
democracy and the history and on how on
history writing on historiography
he is the author of so many single one
thing but and I'll just tell you about a
couple a history of prejudice which we
discussed today in class race caste and
difference in
less routine violence nation fragments
histories the construction of
communalism in colonial India the
ascendancy of the Congress it was a
probation remember partition violence
nationalism history his work has been
collected in the gun and upon de l'homme
nimis and he has many many articles and
chapters to numerous to become but just
as a founding member of subaltern
studies
why would be critical of traditional
Marxist histories so Baldwin studies
pushed against the idea that the elites
were a key proponent of anti colonial
consciousness and resistance it
criticized nationalist historiography
and focused on emergent political and
social movements of those who were
outside of hegemonic power structures
and they produce in the sense what he
calls an umbrella term the subaltern to
capture the Harwich may be off voices
and participation in these movements and
his contributions have changed so much
in the writing and the history of
salvation drawing attention to cost and
gender the processes of making of
subjects and history itself as a me
memory his books on partition of Indiana
and constant communities of my required
works on the topic for everyone who
teaches in these fields so ensure that
he has made powerful and immense
contributions however I'm the segment
unlike some of the other supportive
scholars who focus on the history of
politics of India solely from a certain
point he has been active and developing
a dialogue between the students and
social scientists working on global
north and the south of the world and in
the South he also means the south south
of the United States
works these posted workshops and created
dialogue from thinking about different
cells right and has published on these
topics anthologies that put together the
results of the workshops that he's
hosted cebollas citizens and their
histories investigations from India have
a u.s. sub alternate and DIF
investigations from the north and I'm
not mad he's currently working on two
projects one compared to study the
practice of democracy and the second a
history of in the locational family at
home thank you very much in the pub
Thank You hazel Thank You Salone for
making my visit so comfortable and
smooth and Thank You mr. Frankie for
enabling this invitation and for the
seminar that you have enabled them to
put together a wonderful sermon I can
second what in the file said I enjoyed
meeting the students very much and had a
very nice discussion with them that said
I won't tell you any jokes now which I
usually do at the beginning of a talk I
I won't do it because I've got quite a
lot to say as in the pal says I'm
working on two different things in this
particular piece in some ways fits both
projects one is a reflection on the the
promise and the perils of democracy and
the under needs of democracy if you like
and one section of that 1/3 of the book
is about politics in hidden places one
of those hidden spaces is the home and
my other work is really an attempt to
think about the history of 2010
to India which I will talk about today
from the location of men in the home
which is not a common commonly used
entry point the home is investigative in
all sorts of ways and I'll talk about
that but men in the home list so for a
variety of reasons so what I'm going to
talk about today will actually be part
of both projects and how it appears in
different places I should tell you that
I wrote this up for the first time in
Hindi I actually wrote a twenty thousand
word essay academic essay in Hindi which
I had never done before we were trained
in English that's our academic language
I'd written lots of journalistic pieces
in Hindi but I never done an academic
recently the material that I'm using
here comes from great Hindi writers from
autobiographies from the fiction written
in Hindi and I felt it was very
important for me to address that Hindi
speaking world and I'm the scholarship
Cerrone not just like ships passing in
the night
because they read my stuff they read the
Omnibus repeatedly and then they would
talk to me in seminars and I go to their
seminars I felt that this was work that
I wanted to address to them and get a
response and then says something about
colonialism and our languages and
training my Indian colleagues who know
Hindi very well when they saw the Hindi
piece said where's the English said it's
been a long time we can't read this it's
difficult produced the ignition so I've
been working in the English version as
well which in any case would be part of
these other projects okay so that said
let me begin with what I've entitled for
the moment the home and the world men in
the home in India's anti-colonial moment
and I'll explain why I use invoke the
home in the world and men in the home I
want to begin by making two rather
obvious points about the home in the
world
in modern India the first is to note the
very dramatic changes that have taken
place since the later 19th century since
the beginning of the anti-colonial
struggle in the later 19th century and
through through the decades of the early
and middle 20th century these are
dramatic and I will refer to some of
them at the same time I want to note
what is equally obvious how little has
changed some things have changed
dramatically and so much remains
unchanged as one would have thought at
the beginning of this period that's of
anti-colonial struggle in the later 19th
century and the early 20th multiple
marriages were widespread especially in
upper caste upper and middle caste
circles respectable circles throughout
the country child marriage was common
and there was little expectation that
women had a right to formal education
let alone salary jobs or political
rights very little this is change out of
recognition I mean it's not possible by
the middle of the 20th century even the
watered down version of the Hindu code
bill which was passed by the Indian
Parliament and it was of much watered
down version from what was initially
proposed by the law ministry and others
even that had brought about fundamental
changes I just list a few of these for
you the Hindu Marriage Act of 1955 made
bigamy a cognos cognizable crime and
fixed the minimum age of marriage for
women and men at 15 and 18 and there was
later raised in 1978 to 18 and 21
there's an interesting question why
women should be at 15 and then 18 and
men should have a higher minimum wage
but there it is the Hindu succession Act
of 1956 strengthened property rights for
women wives widows and daughters
including adopted daughters for all of
them in relation to marriage in
inheritance
although the claims of Hindu daughters
still fell far short of the rights of
daughters and the Muslim law where to
the daughter receives only half what the
son gets
there were steps to provide maintenance
and expand health and welfare measures
for women and girls but other critical
and a whole range of critical advances
came with the grant of citizenship to
all adult inhabitants of the land which
had which happened as soon as India
developed its constitution 1950 adult
franchise irrespective of gender
ethnicity caste religion language or
place of birth the right to vote
education and employment and full
participation in the social political
and cultural life of the nation that
declaration those ideals make a huge
difference they actually produce very
different kinds of patterns they produce
very different kinds of opportunities
and for women as for Dalits as for other
marginalized communities a whole range
of new political contexts emerge which
remain constrained which remain as I say
in many many many ways where patriarchy
for example really Institute's itself is
reinstituted in very significant ways
now since I'm concerned about men in the
home I want to say the special sanctity
accorded to family and home in spite of
all these changes in the declaration of
very very fine far-reaching radical
goals in spite of that the special
sanctity accorded to family and home and
to the Indian woman as part of the
assertion of national pride against
Western colonialism against the
debasement of India and its heritage and
so on ensured that the new rights and
opportunities that were promised brought
with them an uncommon and uncommon ly
articulated set of burdens for Indian
womanhood I want to take a slightly
unusual route to revisit this history of
a reform new patriarchy it's been it's
been investigated people have written
about it waiver I want to do this
through an exploration of Indian men's
rhetoric and performance in and around
the home this approach may help focus
some of the subtler and perhaps
unconscious procedures commitments and
beliefs
that led to the institution of a widely
touted traditional hierarchy in the home
and the world
I put traditional in inverted commas
because it's a new tradition it's
produced over this period the title of
my talk of course invoke surrender nath
tagore famous novel guru berry the home
and the world which portrays not just a
physical but a metaphorical division
like other writings of the period the
late nineteenth and the early 20th
centuries it distinguishes the inner
from the outer in a larger sense the
material and the spiritual the colonized
and they're not so easily colonized or
contaminated and in a spiritual
uncolonized domain embodied in the home
the woman the mother the goddess this
was symbolic importance while I invoke
Tagore at the home in the world
I also invoke another powerful if lesser
known text Chevron II Davies premchand
her may this is the wife of the great
who do Hindi writer Prem chant probably
the greatest in the writer of the early
decades of the 20th century she Ronnie
Davies his second wife and after his
death sometime a little after his death
she writes this memoir this account of
prem chant in the home called Prem
Shankar me and I take inspiration from
her account reinvestigate the history of
Indian men in the home people like from
gendered Hindustani aadmi garment which
is what my Hindi piece is entitled to
ask what this history of history of men
in the home tells us about the 20th
century transformation of the home and
the world the history of men in the home
remains amongst the great unwritten
history of the saga of modern India
given the axiomatic equation of women
and children with the home there has
been substantial exploration of the
history of women in family
and home even a sample of the more
important academic publications makes
very very long list
the scholarship includes significant
writings on the role of man as
legislator and model instructor in the
home the mutual constitution of the new
man and the new woman which is
legislated and refigured notions of
masculinity and femininity in the 19th
and 20th centuries much of this latter
work has circled around the abstract
figure of the modern Indian man Hindu or
Muslim but more often Hindu woman the
model marriage and women's negotiations
of existing or emerging prescriptions
and constraints there's now as many of
you will know also growing by a body of
literature on masculinity separately
which you know and yet there is
comparatively little examination of
Indian men's understanding of their
obligations inside the home inside the
domestic space and I want to focus on
that with the ossified common sense of a
domestic world people largely by women
and children it is almost
counterintuitive to think of men in the
home it seems to be important to old
alter the visual of the domestic by
reflecting on the history of men and
women precisely in that space I examine
the detailed writings of three prominent
male thinkers writers and activists on
their lives in the home in the context
of their views on the realignments
necessary for a modern Democratic
culture in country for the history of
men in the home points to several
deep-seated ambiguities in the making of
the goods society and the accomplished
human being in colonial and postcolonial
India in the promises that are made to
ourselves as it were so the three people
are going to talk about are very well
known certainly well known in India
and you will be familiar with some of it
Rajendra Prasad was the first of them
born 1884 he died in 1963 he was a
devoted guardian lawyer and Congress
leader he became president of India's
Constituent Assembly and then the first
President of India it's a very very
prominent public worker and wrote a 600
page autobiography which I will use and
talk about in Hindi then he he was also
forced to translate it into English so
he produced the short version in English
dhanpatrai whom I've referred to
Premchand born 1889 1936 his is as I
said acknowledged as probably the
greatest Hindi Urdu writer of the early
decades of the 20th century and
outstanding chronicler of the national
struggle outstanding chronicler of the
times that's the way he's thought of he
also rewrote Hindi and although the
languages were transformed in his in his
handling of it they became the language
of the people in urban India urban North
India but nonetheless said a very very
significant move the last of my people
the loss of the protagonists a man
called Kedarnath Pandey no relative born
1893 died 1963 he was christened rahul
sankrityayan when he became a Buddhist
monk and I'm going to use the name rahul
sankrityayan for much of it it's very
very well known in Bihar all over
northern India he's known very well in
Tibet he's known in Central Asia and in
Russia as the man who rediscovered
revived actually saved the study of
Buddhism in India because the texts had
disappeared and this man walked hundreds
and hundreds of miles he walked over the
mountains you know into Tibet he
traveled to Central Asia he traveled to
China he traveled to Sri Lanka he
traveled all over the place
to try and recover these decks and
brought back bullock loads of these
things which were being discarded so
he's an extraordinary extraordinary
scholar and
[Music]
investigator he was held as I'm saying
this because perhaps he'll be less well
known than the other two he was hailed
as a Maha pundit great scholar his
mastery of numerous languages and
authorship of 125 published works in
five different languages
fifty thousand pages in all an
extraordinary kind of achievement he was
at the same time and in indefatigable
political and cultural activist
successively a reformist Hindu educator
a Buddhist a communist and organizer of
peasant movements and prominent
prominent nationalist worker Congress
worker in Bihar and a campaigner for the
establishment of Hindi as the national
language of India so that's the
background all three of these people
again it's enough for me to just say
this in passing all three well it
dedicated to the production of a new
India a reformed India a democratic
India in which women and girls would
have the same rights as men so they all
talk about socially from the need for
social reform they all talk about the
need for women's and girls education
they they talk about the need to ban
pardha they talk about the need to end
the confinement of women in in home and
community they talk against the
confinement of widows who were not
allowed to remarry amongst upper castes
and Milkha Singh in Hindu India they
talk against child marriage all of those
things they advocate these things very
strongly and I put this down I say all
of this because it's important to
recognize to remember the idealism of
these people the the dedicated strong
[Music]
effort desire to produce this change
world therefore their place in the home
and their their rhetoric around the home
becomes all the more interesting
Rob Schenck return is perhaps the most
radical of these
in terms of his rhetoric actually in
terms of his life also he called for the
realization of human potential through
unfettered exploration and pursuit of
each person's physical emotional
intellectual and spiritual yearnings men
and women alike is a articulated sexual
desire something he said women too must
have the right to fulfill all this very
few people spoke about these things
openly and the way in which he did at
the time he was quick to defy social
conventions ordering beef loudly in
restaurants you know in railway stations
and on highways eating with people of
all religions and castes marrying far
outside his community a Russian woman
when he was in Russia teaching there and
a young Dalit woman of Nepalese origin
in the last stages of his life yet he
seemed to remain and this is the point
that I'll return to at the end of what I
have to say remain relatively unaware
throughout his life of his own
dependence as that of other men and
women on the care and support provided
by family the cooking and cleaning
they are bringing of children the
tending of the aged and the sick it's
almost as though this doesn't count in
the arguments that he is putting forward
it's not part of that argument it's
somewhere else and so that's an
interesting these people were all all
three of them Russians Prashad
premchand and sankirtan are all born in
I'm going to say upper caste even though
Raj Rajendra Prasad was a Caius and
Caius the writerly scribal caste began
to get a kind of respectable status only
in mobile times and it's really 18th
19th century that they come to be
thought of as upper caste until then
they were thought of as shudra which is
the lower caste category they are not
just raising the pressure Premchand to
the skies and they both distinguished
writers very distinguished with their
thought of as upper caste
Kedarnath Pandey was of course
indubitably upper caste he was from
pundit
family anything they're born in upper
caste households in in Rajendra Prasad
case in a very well-to-do some in the a
family very well to rule and holding
family in western Bihar
aristocratic in a very traditional sense
aristocratic well-off the other two are
from much smaller Zamindari families
their land holding is small and they the
families in both cases sank Rotarians as
well as from chance had to find other
jobs schoolteacher in business of some
kind you know whatever they could to
make ends meet or to live the life of
the respectable those or something but
nonetheless I want to mark the fact that
these are people who come from that
rural respectable background and adhere
culturally to what I call ISM in the
recolor this aristocratic rural
upbringing and its tenets it's it's
concerned with respectability it's
concerned with the status of the family
the step we want to mark right all three
of them of course make their names in
urban professional ways right as lawyers
writers scholars activists of various
kind these are urban elite Western
educated even if their primary language
was Hindi for all three of them
[Music]
intellectuals activists thinkers they
are part of the entirely new crop of new
middle classes in colonial India in late
late 19th century and 20th century India
there's a whole crop of these
professionals who are becoming very very
significant lawyers doctors teachers
engineers what have you there now joined
by the corporate world where the
corporate sector much more this was not
a very major part of the middle classes
in India until the 1950s or 60s it is
now of course almost the predominant
part but they weren't I want to mark
that rural urban shift and the move
towards professional
plus mores and goals as something that
marked the entire period it was
something that lower caste people
lower-class people aspire to in the same
way so what I'm going to say about these
three upper caste relatively well-to-do
comfortable background rule with
respectable people that kind of pattern
that kind of aspiration that kind of
history actually speaks to the history
of a much wider range of social groups
in India who aspire to the same sort of
thing Muslim and Hindu upper caste and
lower caste I suggest they don't all
have the same opportunities as but the
aspiration is very much of that kind
that said for these three people from
this kind of rural respectable
background their kind of background
necessitated or made it easy mrs. mrs.
stated is right made it common in any
case for them to have child marriages
all three were married at the age of 11
or 12 and one case 15
that's the Premchand Mary's last sank
retain the most openly rebellious of the
three as I said condemned society for
the outrage of sanctioning this kind of
marriage at the age of 11 or 12 when you
know nothing about it when you know you
do not even know what it means
just put that in context some of you
will know this from Gandhi's
autobiography Gandhi was mad maganda
Mohandas Karamchand was betrothed at the
age of seven to a girl aged seven he
recalls that he was told and that he
remembered that he had been betrothed
two times before that before he was
seven two girls who died and so he it
will betroth again and so this is very
very widespread very common in in these
circles I'm going to tell you or tell
you about these
the cake on the child marriage which
both sank return sankirtan abandoned it
fake sound sank retain and preemption
both both abandon their first marriages
the child manages preemption goes on to
marry a second time she runny Davey the
woman whose memo I mentioned to you sang
cotton marries twice more once when he
is in Russia teaching once later in life
and I'll speak about all of this in some
ways but Prasad Rajendra Prasad the
president in dutiful skin of a wealthy
landed family accepted his marriage he
only had the one child man he lived with
his wife for the rest of his life quite
how I'm going to talk about that you
know quite what it meant and he writes
he writes critically about that in
interesting ways with that said let me
just get to the heart of the argument I
want to make which is what men saw as
the home as what the home meant as what
the home offered and what the home
required all of those those sorts of
things and I'm going to attend to three
features that mark the marriages of all
these protagonists the authority of
elders is very marked the call of public
work very marked in this time of
anti-colonial struggle and the
dependence of the men not so well marked
they were very marked if you read it not
marked in their own reckoning about what
these things what these are features
found in the marital histories of all
three men I shall consider them serially
the authority of the elders the call of
public work and the dependence of the
men and I'll do so through the
individual examples just to try and keep
the thing from being even more confusing
than it might still be so I'm going to
use the Rajendra Prasad one marriage
which was the child marriage
with which he lived all his life to
discuss the authority of the elders
which will appear in the other cases I'm
going to use prim chance see I've said
at one point and I skipped that I've
said that their marriages fall into a
very interesting pattern even in the
cases where a person married only once
or twice rather than three times
sankirtan marries three times and first
is a child marriage the second is a love
marriage you know he thinks of it that
way
the third though he doesn't think of it
that way is a needs marriage it's a
dependence marriage an old person was
sick and not well and I suggest that the
marriages of men in in these times
certainly and perhaps today actually
partake of all those moments the child
marriage the love marriage and the
dependent marriage and it's interesting
to think how they do so why it persists
and the way in which it does so prim
gents love marriage which Chevron adavi
is the one I'm going to talk about I
want to discuss in that particularly the
call of public work and how that public
work pushes against or is intentioned
with the idea of a marriage of desire
okay and in San Rotarians case I want to
focus on the needs marriage even though
these are not strictly separable I mean
you know this there's love of a very
significant kind in Schenck returns lost
marriage without question with a woman
who was 19 when he was 56 that's when he
married so 37 year gap it's it's a
phenomenal and it develops into a very
close affectionate relationship there's
some but the needs element the
dependence of the man who refuses to
recognize in a sense that dependency is
critical so the authority of the elders
both Rajendra Prasad and sank retain
refer to their child marriage when they
were 11 or 12 as tamasha spectacle kale
play you know
game and rezoned Prashad in his
autobiography says you know as a child
my sister and I we used to play the
marriages of dolls and my marriage was a
bit like that I knew nothing about what
it meant I know nothing about what
responsibilities his wife was probably
younger than him though we don't have an
exact date of birth it was almost
certainly younger than him would have
known no more than he does he marks this
thing the child marriage and the kind of
constraints that in his circles came
with a marriage the point is the
marriage especially for landed wealthy
people in the countryside is a marriage
not between two individuals again what
I'm saying apply is much more widely but
for them it is categorically a marriage
between families about the protection of
wealth about the maintenance of status
and and so on so forth and so he talks
about the confinement of women status
right the confinement of women in the
inner quarters he talks about his
sister-in-law his older brother's wife
would come and he said this is all I
could think about at the terms of
marriage that one day just as my
sister-in-law had come to live with us
my wife would come to live with us and
then he talks about the confinement of
the the to his sister-in-law and his
wife to single rooms around a courtyard
in the back of the house they were not
allowed into the courtyard for most of
the life of his mother until his mother
died they were not allowed to step out
into the courtyard except under very
heavy protection curtain doff so if they
needed to go to the toilet if they
needed to go for a bath they would come
out of the of the room and they would be
escorted by maid servants who held these
curtains around them just in case of
some stray eyes and stress were what
young boys serving in the courtyard
coming in to help with the cooking or
with the cleaning of that
the cook who used to come across the
courtyard had to announce that he was
coming so that these women would not be
seen in there so all of this went on the
confinement to one room dark probably
damp at many times here produces
arthritis in both the women very soon
several people have written about
Rajendra Prasad own wife who was then
the first lady she was the wife of the
President of India lay in late in her
life about how she had bent over like an
old woman
at a very young age because she she was
made to sit in that posture all of the
time not moving just sitting in that
posture and that became her posture from
quite quite young age it's very striking
that Rajendra Prasad for everything that
he's he speaks out about and so on but
that should be banned diaries should be
it should be stopped it was not able to
either persuade his parents or to fight
to enable these women his wife his
sister-in-law to step out of that room
freely while his mother was alive it's
only after his mother dies that that
freedom comes let's say it's an
extraordinary sort of thing but there
were other aspects of this thing prasad
writes in that autobiography which is
written forty-five years into his
marriage he says we've been married
there's a 4/4 page four and a half page
chapter on his marriage in a 600 page
autobiography because the autobiography
is all about his public work yeah it's
all about the work that he needed to do
for India and that everyone needs to do
for the country and further for the
community but in this four-and-a-half
way a page thing he says we've been
married for 45 years but I'm not sure we
would live together for even forty five
months and that's very significant
because he was out all of the time and
like other people in that community his
wife and his there one son one reason
really lived with parents lived with the
elders in
the family home in their socratic
household as it was and he was away as
it as a student then studying law in
Calcutta then practicing law and
Calcutta then returning to Patna the
capital of Bihar as a lawyer when when a
high court was opened in that in that
province all of this time his wife and
child stay where they are they come
occasionally to meet him when he comes
to but now they come and spend a little
time in the men they come to meet him
through most of his life when he is ill
when he is in jail because he's jailed
repeatedly by the British it's those
times that they come together when he
goes back is when he's tired when he's
exhausted when he's ill he goes home to
recuperate to recover and he has made
remarkable statement about what that
marriage meant in the early days he
refers to his and presumably his wife's
suppressed adolescent feelings once
they'd been married and she'd come over
there to live in their home once he says
he was home for the holiday his and his
wife had had an attack of color
he was understandably concerned however
and I'm quoting now from the English
I've translated this but it was
considered bad form to show much
interest in one's wife I wanted to see
her and get to know her this is early in
the marriage but could not ask anyone no
expressed the desire to do so this is
not marriage between these two
individuals got to do with much more
right perhaps it did not occur to my
folks that I too was interested in her
health he only says that we can add and
her all right so this is what goes on
through his life and I'm I will return
to this in a moment I perhaps I should
say this too that the women in the home
these younger women to get their the
some fulfillment of a desire for some
movement
some travel something else sings through
pilgrimages this is the one thing they
are allowed to do and so his
sister-in-law like another widowed
sister they spend all of that time and
all of the money that they've got in
doing pilgrimages and when his wife has
the opportunity she does the same and
interestingly towards the end of the
freedom struggle and and Gandhi's become
the Mahatma and he is the the great soul
he's become a saintly figure they're
allowed to go to his ashram they allowed
to go and go to Gandhi related events
more pilgrimages this is but outside
that they could not travel except when
Rajendra Prasad was in or when he was in
jail when they needed to come support
him and do it now I'm going to again say
more about Rajendra Prasad the authority
of the elders surfaces in in in the
other cases too and you'll see it in the
case of preemption that I moved moved to
now but I want to emphasize here the
cause of national work which of course
is absolutely fundamental in Bridgend
bouchard's case and you know he says it
you know the call of national work I had
to I had to be there so you know it
makes no apology for the fact that he
was never home right and that the only
times he went was when he was ill or
tired or she was in on one or two
occasions but anyway premchand is
schooled like Prasad and I imagine
sankirtan on the naturalness joys and
expectations of wedlock even in a child
marriage and so he's quite enthusiastic
about the child marriage he is going to
have at fifteen he's very disappointed
as soon as he's married he's
disappointed because it turns out it was
arranged by a stepmother and her
that family and whoever arranged it must
have arranged it for money wealth
reasons you know calculations of
financial benefit and so on
didn't point out that she was slightly
older than him that she was dark or
darker than him
and that she was as they said not so
good-looking not so attractive inside
that she even had a limp she was
pockmarked according to various stories
now nobody knows she has not been named
in any writing by Prem gem or by all his
biographers his children who have
written about him and there's a lot of
writing the man's an extraordinary man
but his she's never named and this huge
huge colossal conflict between his child
marriage wife and his step mother-in-law
who lives in the home with them with him
and he has to this is part of his
commitment he looks after all his elders
he looks after all the relatives on
every side whoever wants and he's not
very well off so it's quite a struggle
that he does it this fighting leads at
one point to his wife seeking to commit
suicide at a time when he's at home she
often as the result of a fight just goes
home to help her parents to her natal
home which is a couple of districts away
and so you know not far she often does
that after the suicide attempts which he
luckily is not successful
premchand is at home and the resolution
is she should be sent home and she she
goes home permanently as it happens so
this is a good 10 years of living
together not living together probably as
happy husband and wife happy spouses and
I don't know nobody has the record to
say what the spousal relationship was
the emotional
shall we say so relationship was not a
strong one the physical relationship may
have been there we just don't know
enough about it all we know is there was
this contentious period which went on
long term
within a year of her going home after
this event he marries again and he
marries to a large extent because his
stepmother in the who's the authority
figure creating a lot of these trouble
insists that he should marry again you
must have a good marriage
you must have children which he does as
it happens and he marries a child widow
he marries a widow he's been writing
about the fate of widows the terrible
condition of widows this must not be
allowed they must be allowed to remarry
so he goes out and more or less arranges
it for himself he does it without
telling his village in the village and
they informed me later when once he's
got he is really to marry she had been
married before and had at the age of 11
or something and had died and her
husband had died while she was still in
her teens and so he marries she's 17
years of age he's 25 his first marriage
lasted for that that 10-year period
right and she's attractive and
soft-spoken and polite and reserved
according to observers and then
according to parish and I think to some
extent he says it differently and he
comes across in this absolutely
beautiful moving tribute that she writes
about him and his life in the home he
comes across as an extraordinarily
lovable man a man who is democratic in
the extreme who doesn't like servants
working for him who doesn't like his
wife working for him who helps with the
children who helps dress them up who
does what he can outside the home he
helps coach the children he you know it
he comes across as affable desirable you
know and he's known and again this fits
the character he's known for his
resounding laughter an anthropologist
from the United States went to do some
work on him and wrote a book about him
and Robert Swan is his name Swan when he
went to the village said he wanted to go
to the home of Fringe and the writer and
people were a bit puzzled who you talk
me when and so when he'd explain it he
said oh the man who laughs right you can
hear him there he is you know so it's
just in character and Chevron is
Reconstruction Chevron and Davey his
second wife's his reconstruction of
their married life is a playful account
of a blossoming love and understanding
adventurous moments romantic exchanges
and companionship his desire to teach
her languages and skills she didn't know
she knew Hindi she didn't know do
English both of which he knew well and
her willingness and success in learning
perhaps more than he anticipated because
she becomes a writer too she goes to
jail in the they had this kind of
conflict she will think both of them
want to go to jail if possible and he's
never able to go to jail she goes to
jail in in an anti British you know
demonstration exam but he with all of
that he says nothing once again to his
mother-in-law and the mother-in-law
lives with them for long periods even
though he's now a schoolteacher at first
you to many different places she says
nothing she he sells to her to his wife
repeatedly you are the woman of the home
you must be in charge but he says
nothing to his mother and who is in
charge and she refuses to get into a
conflict with the older woman and she
too goes to her natal home as often as
required
she says later on in this in this more
biography she says I spent a month in
his home and 11 months in mine mine 8 no
appearance on it was eight years into
their marriage the Premchand discussed
this thing openly with Shivani
and he then said you know I miss you
when you go very rare
people don't say these sorts of things
in that kind of circle but he says it
and he says you know I wish you'd stay
we should take you know I have given
myself to you I've given everything in
this house belongs to you answer and
then he says and this is what moves her
and then he says my mother died when I
was very young I've never had the love
of a mother okay and this registers it
strikes a chord this is what a woman
must be Chevron a baby feels exactly the
same thing right the woman is the mother
and she says that from that day I had a
very different feeling towards him I I
began to enjoy being with him I began to
talk develop I became not just the ruler
of the home but the ruler of his heart I
had complete authority over him sure
it's this in retrospect and again
demonstration of that kind of thing you
know he's a very prominent writer by the
nineteen twenties and thirties 1933 like
no university honors him they invite him
to me and Garland's Flowers has happens
in you know these these occasions in
India always balance flowers Chevron the
baby was gone to the ceremony with him
and he are sitting under a tree in a
break during during the proceeding
saying that under a tree and the
university lawns and he takes off the
garland of flowers oh he's carrying it
in his hand and he puts it over her head
and he said there we are nowadays now
married out of our heart's desire you
know we may have been married some other
work with here we're married out for
Hospital desire yet even with that love
marriage right the constraints are
phenomenal and the constraints are he's
this great writer she's beginning to
write when she begins to write and as
you would expect male journalists male
critics and so on say oh he she has been
writing this he writes it right and he
has to respond to that repeatedly so he
says to her I wish he wouldn't write
you know I wish you near you don't
aren't you happy enough doing all the
other things you're looking after
children keeping house so well inside
aren't you happy you know I told you or
doin I taught you English and so on but
I wish oh okay so in any event I should
should rush on he doesn't want it right
because of the complications he himself
must carry on with with public work with
that commitment and at that same time
where he has garland at her and said we
are now married out of our own desire
sitting there in the lawns of Lucknow
University under this tree he sees these
young men and women wandering around
students wandering around laughing
chatting having fun getting to know one
another look at these people he says and
she writes quotes this acting like
princes and princesses out on a stroll
the girls flighty as butterflies and
then he goes on to say sensuous pleasure
will never bring independence and I
think he means national as well as
individual independence comes through
asceticism service and sacrifice and so
here's the last thing I want to say
about him and it it is it it's what got
me thinking about this question of men
in the home 1935 the year before he died
he wrote a letter in English to somebody
who was writing a biography of Prem Chen
well who asked him a set of questions
and this paragraph is worth reading my
married life has nothing of romance
she Rani Devi and him and she has
written about this playful wonderful
blossoming love and my married life has
nothing of romance it is just the common
type my first wife died in 1904 and an
alternate effect she was actually alive
even at this time and she runny Davey
did not know this and many years into
the marriage when she found out by
accident but anyway my first wife was an
unfortunate woman not at all good
looking and all they're not satisfied
with her I pull
uncomplainingly just as all traditional
husband's do when she died I married a
beloved child widow and I'm fairly happy
with her she has picked up some literary
tastes in sometimes write stories she is
a fearless bold uncompromising lady I'm
happy with her not claiming what she
cannot give and here's here's the crunch
well life has been always to me work
work work
even when I was in government service I
devoted my whole time to literary
pursuits I take pleasure in my work
that's what I should be doing that is
what it's about and I just want to say
that one of the things that comes
through in him and in Rajendra Prasad is
the nation as mother very important
something you must be devoted to but the
woman has mother the woman has kind of
symbolic of the nationís mother and
Rajendra Prasad writes about this in a
very moving moving very interesting
passage about his first meeting with
Gandhi's wife which was in Champlin in
1917 when there was this peasant
education and ba Kasturba Gandhi came to
help and support and Gandhi put her to
work cooking for everybody
dismissing the cook she's very capable
she's young man she's slender and so on
which is very key and resident pressure
later on having met her got to know her
very well says she was the very ideal
I'm quoting she was the very ideal of a
Hindu woman a symbol of Indian culture
and a bundle of love she was truly bah
bah means mother and bar she remained to
all of us on one occasion Gandhiji said
to me I too get great pleasure and
calling her bah the two of them had of
their own accord given up the relations
that are commonly prevalent between
husband and wife she had in truth become
mother to him this was the idea and in a
funny way this was the ideal for Prem
chant in a very strange way this was the
idea
I just want to spend five minutes
talking about round sound again always
I'm not going to be able to do justice
to what he does here he married in he
married as a child left that marriage
again seven or eight years later but he
rebelled against it quite quite quickly
and only late in life wrote dedicated a
book to his first wife saying to my
first wife whose life has been ruined on
the altar of my ambition and he actually
says that he's moved his he's upset
nonetheless 3738 he's teaching in
Leningrad for two months he meets a
young woman there who's his own age who
is extremely accomplished a very
wonderful linguist and indologist as
she's she's developing and they get
together yes he says they don't I don't
think they officially married and he has
a son with her seven months later but
he's only allowed to stay two months he
doesn't have visas he doesn't get the
permission and so on he comes back to
India he only goes back seven years
later when finally visitors come through
when he does go back he lives with his
wife and his son for two years and he
has a really hard time of it he finds
all the housework that she attends to
and that she asks him to do she's lived
through the Leningrad siege she has
earned two medals for the work she's
done during that time but he says she is
not the Lola the Elena that I knew seven
years ago anything to yourself yet think
again she's had siblings who have died
of starvation they have eaten leather
they have survived in the worst possible
and he knows all of this but he doesn't
seem to register and he says you know
she's not interested in studying in in
reading writing and that's what my life
is all about and so there's a great deal
of friction and when he leaves after 25
months in learn read teaching living
with her when he leaves finally
he says as he bought ship he writes it
was as if a weight had been lifted off
my heart the call of life's duty he
writes was not willing to be bound by
the chain of illusory love attachment to
home wife and son now I wonder I I'm
stressing this because a short while
later he marries Kamla this 19 year old
woman 37 years younger than him because
he needs someone to be with him all the
time he says so he says so in so many
words he develops a fantastic close
relationship with her but he goes over
the same problem they have two children
in 1953 and 1955 he is outraged is
probably not too strong away for the
amount of time she spends doing
housework
he says the difference between gods and
human beings and he writes this in a
thrown off by chapter and six-volume
autobiography you know 4,000 pages he
writes the difference between gods and
humans is that the gods don't have to do
homework housework yeah this cooking and
cleaning and so on so that's what he
wants to be and that's what he believes
all men and women should be the superior
being they accomplished human being man
or woman must be of that kind wandering
the wanderer is what is he writes a book
called gamma curses the philosophy of
wandering the religion wandering which
he preaches and strangely enough he's
preaching he says to leave one's wife is
a good thing for the nation because it's
society's fault they've they forced you
into this and you know leaving home home
is wherever you are there you know it's
it's a it's completely contradictory
it's a very beautiful piece of writing a
philosophy of wandering in with Jesus
Christ and Muhammad and the Buddha and
guru nanak and then and saraswathi all
the great religious leaders of the world
all the sages of the world were
Wanderers that is how they
what they had to learn that is where
wisdom came from that is where I can't
they accomplished human being lives but
Camila should do that so he fights with
that many many times because he says
first of all you should study all the
time you shouldn't be doing this other
thing her poor relatives from kalimpong
from northeast india actually come to
help when the children she has been
transcribing and typing his stuff she
has been giving him insulin injections
all this sort of stuff but she's he
keeps saying to her why do you spend so
much time washing and cleaning and
cooking why don't you let the servants
do it even when the servants on leave
and when the children are this little he
fights with her to go with him to China
and to Tibet he acknowledges it and this
is a trip he wants which is not yet been
sanctioned but he fights with her for
two years to go and the children are 1
and 3 when this fighting starts and she
says how can I do that ultimately he
goes alone he falls ill they all coded
to get him out of hospital a heart
attack there and it takes jobs there so
I mean it's it's a moving it's an
extraordinary account but I just want to
quote to you something she writes she
puts together the last volume of his
autobiography he's dead he's dead the
fifth volume he'd finished it was
published after he died but the sixth
volume he never finished so she writes
it from all the notes that he left the
diaries that he compiled and the notes
she took in two years of being with him
in hospitals from 1961 to 1963 in
hospitals all over the place including
Russia where Lola and the son actually
come to visit finally the last time but
you know you get something of this
peculiar sense an entitlement that men
have that ruminating on their worldviews
and their thoughts come there refers to
an admirer of Ronson return of her
husband who proclaimed in an
extraordinary display of arrogance that
Rahu geez
marriage to Kamala turned his life into
health
otherwise this person says this admire a
follower of the great scholar otherwise
Rahul ji would have continued fearlessly
to roam the world like a lion right and
she responds very succinctly in in this
last volume of the autobiography because
she's put it together so shares comments
every now and then she says yes Lions
roam fearless as long as they have
strengthened their bodies and lions to
need the company of lionesses and lions
to grow old and die one day
Rahul ji is no longer the daring Rahul
ji of the past now he needs an injection
of insulin before every meal and has
many other bodily ailments and that's
all she says she could have said so much
more but she wasn't and so this is the
point I want to make about this time
particularly and about this very
progressive idealistic well-intentioned
you know deeply dedicated committed men
seeking to make a new India that the
blindness is extraordinary the
philosophy of Higher Being of wandering
that rolls and croton preaches a
philosophy of itinerant see right in
which the evolved enlightened human
being unburdened by worldly or familial
attachments roams freely as a lion
exploring experimenting learning and
preaching to build the good Society this
must run up against noon they luckily
which is watch what he calls the chapter
on his on housework noonday liquor is
literally oil no salt oil would so
housework of all kinds
if master animal ran up against that
premchand characterization of his life
as work work work Rajendra Prasad
unflagging flagging the education to a
life of public service at the cost of
time spent at home I in line with sank
Rotarians philosophy of wandering in a
peculiar way similar tendencies
interestingly of course I noticed in men
who do none of the same kind of work
none of that they have none of that
intellectual or political commitment
they are not Wanderers they are not
seekers of wisdom but they are still out
of the home because it requires their
being out of the home they need to go
very often unannounced right I'm going
to read you the last paragraph and then
I've gone on a bit longer than I should
have
Rajendra Prasad Premchand and sank Ratan
somehow believed that they were at
liberty to choose between public and
private work the women in their lives
knew this was fantasy ago the philosophy
of non-attachment wandering and public
service preached by sank Ratan and
indirectly by preme Chandan Prashad as
well was always up against the
inescapability of Montaigne luckily or
attachment that was accepted but not
necessarily cherished by their wives the
effacement and these and other men's
accounts of the role of the parent
usually the mother as caregiver provider
sustainer nurse for children for elders
for husbands and for men in general
places a huge and unacknowledged burden
on women from that time to this I want
to say in India the woman's own lives
and commentaries tell a more complex
story of social contradictions of
anguish and pain desire and love and not
least responsibility to those around
responsibility to the home that has been
carefully nurtured and built for them
the struggle to balance formal
citizenship freedom opportunity
education paid work and public
engagement with biological and social
reproduction of family and community has
been constant it's it's a constant
battle and it's unyielding it has no
easy resolution until we take up the
problem of men in the home I'll stop
there
[Applause]
sure
I'm sorry if I exhausted you but I went
on a bit longer than I should
t1 start and then
and a generation so yeah I guess what a
lovely I guess within this context of
whether you have a sense of the longer
the other question was about the role
whether any of the figures that you see
here that you study or other figures
male figures are connecting something
like the desire something like brain
Chung's expression that his life is work
with the desire with the need to educate
women so that they can be in so that you
can do intellectual work with women in
the home if that makes sense whether
there's a kind of there's a there's a
the kind of integrity of intellectual
work and the recognition that women
engage in that work - and the idea that
that work might be done in the homes of
the home is not merely a place to
recuperate but also a place in which to
engage theirs but interesting visions I
use love marriage just because it's
convenient term and the Hindi doesn't
actually add not pensions and they
certainly doesn't use love marriage
it says desire you know out of our
choice it's that kind of thing and I
think the important thing here is the
love marriage component comes out of a
recognition that companionship is the
modern form of togetherness and what
should mark a marriage companionship is
vital if you push it a little further
and it happens in some cotton it is that
the individual must be allowed to flower
even within this relationship right so
desire all kinds should be expressed
here companionship should allow a
discussion a easy communication and and
constant communication between husband
and wife between partners that's where
that middle element comes it doesn't
always constitute romance in the in the
Bombay Bollywood film where something it
is the question of companionship desire
the flowering of individuality it has
more and more in recent times taken over
this romantic Bollywood sort of thing
where it retains the the tension and the
conflict with duty to the family duty to
the community so in that sense even in
its a revised version it still has that
so a lot of the 1950s and 60s films are
about that love versus duty but I think
the the more for us the more interesting
thing is that desire for companionship
and individual flowering and that
relates to your second book
second question so is the desire for
work and for public work and for
intervention to change things does that
require the education of women yes but
with very strict limits at least
unthought through the first part of the
education of women is that they should
be good companions they should be
literate they should be able to read and
write and they should be good companions
also in the sense that they should be
allies and supporters in this work which
remains unconsciously at least primarily
the work of men so there's there's a
strange sort of what shall we say
slippage there social reform the the
call for a democratic India required
that everybody should have education but
as you know for ever so long home
sciences was what women were taught and
with you know even in public education
even in formal curricula and it's only
recently that that might be challenged
to some extent to a large extent it
remains the case that women are
channeled into certain kinds of subjects
which are seen as more so nursing at
some point becomes okay and so on so
what that would be my short response you
had a question so much
[Music]
yeah it's an interesting question and
there's something interesting about the
absence of an engagement with this with
these issues with the question of the
four stages of the four action in these
people there's a there's a very
modernist take on all of this right and
the take is very much that everyone has
this right there is very little thought
of retiring from it until you die okay
none of them takes this the
philosophical concerns of the
traditional Hindu seriously in two cases
there were not particularly religious
Premchand or sankirtan they both sang
damn for all these a buddhist monk and
andres ammaji preacher for a while you
thinks of himself as a radical reformer
he's a communist you know and that's it
so even as a Buddhist that's what his
primary self understanding is Prem
Chen's very much like that I'm a
socialist and so and so and he says
Toshiro me Vivian on his deathbed he
says oh god if there is a god that's the
service you get that sort of faith resin
Prashad would have been much more
traditional but it's not philosophically
in general and so public work becomes in
modern times that is the way to serve
God that is the way to attain nirvana
if you like to to attend there's a
change here and the change then requires
that everyone has certain kinds of
rights and your primary dedication must
be to the community and and the nation
in that particular instance but the
community can be defined in many ways
yeah okay is really interesting in terms
of the way in which I'm wondering how
the category work itself is something
that is a historical shift there in time
right and so the way in which work
itself becomes disarticulated from
something and do in the home so so I
want to think about the kind of category
of work and the way in which cost
Patriarchate's
right are then even the way in which
work gets configured in this period sort
of through anti-colonialism and after
the reorganization the emergence of
different kinds of work then meshes with
or changes how hosta Patriarchate
functions in the home right and so I
want to think about the work rather than
its work weren't where but it's what
kinds of work
and how did that change patriarchy and
passed me yeah
again very large question your
articulation is perfect that's exactly
what happens and work comes to be
defined in very specific ways here so
work is public work for these particular
people very strongly very actively but
work even for those who are not
intellectually politically committed
like this work is that that is salaried
that brings an income of a certain kind
gives you security of a certain kind
gives you the self-respect of the
educated professional if possible but
otherwise that you've taken steps in
that direction that's the very wide wide
notion that an untaught through sense of
what the modern must have it's not even
sankirtan is is really the one who
pushes these things furthest because he
really thinks about individuality and
desire and stuff that that requires
fulfillment if the human being is to
realize himself herself in modern times
the others don't even articulate in that
way but the articulation of public work
as work and public work then extends in
many many cases just into what the
British used to do you know be the civil
servant be the lawyer be the engineer
business the the kind of the technocrats
and professionals of our time and of
course in most recent it's now the
consumers yeah that's okay that kind of
corporate culture is acceptable as well
it I'm not so sure how much in different
castes and in well-to-do circles
respectable circles work in the home
would ever have been recognized as work
I'm not I'm you know I'd have to read
more carefully and and and think through
that more carefully what I'm saying
obviously does not apply to the vast
majority of working people in the
country right except aspirationally
because aspirationally they would want
to be part of the same drive to produce
that kind of
and that kind of location for
respectability but otherwise the women
were working the men were working
outside and inside the home I'm paid in
many many cases or underpaid in the case
of women almost all the time I think
you're absolutely right to say this is
articulated in a completely new way how
that affects cast battery are key I'm
not so sure except that I think what you
get is a breakdown of the very narrow
limits of cast and the articulation of
identity in terms of those very small
groupings which you could marry within
which you could you know travel within
each wave and so that expands hugely for
all sorts of reasons I think patriarchy
gets reinforced by this call for a
women's education of that particular
kind and for the women's need to perform
their work in the home up to certain
standards cleanliness you know teaching
people how to dress teaching people
languages more than one all of those
sorts of things become so I you know I'm
bed girls part of it as mesmero is part
of it Oh as these people apartment I
don't know that answers your question
yeah
[Music]
exactly similar yeah first thing I want
to say to you
I've talked once before at Emory about
this sort of stuff and colleagues of
mine said what have you told this story
from the point of view of the women and
my short answer to that is this this is
the story that the women would tell I
think come Lysander Stan tells the
stories I just want to mark that first
that these women have a very different
take on what Savage
both children in a week and she running
for all that she shares just that
there's so much tension within that so
it's so self contradictory that that
account she condemns Premchand for all
sorts of things as she she loves him in
in the course of thinking back to what a
wonderful man he was she's still doing
all of that and kumla in publishing the
volume 5 which she did with a few
footnotes and in producing vol 6
actually writes a very different
commentary it's a very very different
account of roles and the greater holds a
greater hands life in which she says
things like I would not have expected
this of somebody as large as big as you
write someone who is such a great
scholar someone whom all all of us
looked up to I would not have expected
this of you tears are emotive right
through her vol 6 all the way through
tears and the nightmare of hospitals all
of that the only thing I've seen sadly
Rajan Prashad didn't have daughter there
are others I'm going to give you a
couple of
samples prim Chandan had a daughter who
was an who even with all his idealism he
did not feel the need to educate to the
same level as his sons it's quite
remarkable it's a very radical thinker
and worker and so-and-so nonetheless he
just falls prey to what is surrounding
them no sound returns third marriage he
has a daughter and a son and I've been
in conversation with both of them
I met Jaya the daughter who's now in her
early 60s I suppose 50 yeah
mid-sixties and when I met Jer I said to
her that I had seen her mother's memoir
off route sankrityayan there was a
little memoir that she wrote secretly
which is fantastic titled Muhammad of
maja pundit the great human being the
great scholar and then it's kind of
critical in various places but it really
is the celebration of this man's
wonderful life
Jay writes a little preface they're just
two pages also in which she says amongst
other things that if my mother had lived
in our time she would have written this
very differently she just says that and
when I asked her but she said I don't
even remember saying it it's quite
striking and I had to remind her and
then say to her I thought I thought that
was really a very powerful statement a
very important statement and I think if
it has been the case that in our
conversations then she has spoken about
it and allowed that something is worth
worth thinking through there so that's
the only thing from this family that I
have got I also want to say that
in the case of Prem Chen's grand
daughters his sons wrote and became very
very distinguished his grandsons had
written and done very well his
granddaughter's one of them particularly
has become a great writer the
granddaughters were
this granddaughter in particular who was
quite a good friend of mine I knew her
from childhood up she was very upset at
what I did when she read the Hindi and
she said you know I don't know why
you're digging all this up Jaya didn't
take that position the men all took that
position the grandsons the sons their
Bronk returns son just was outraged
really angry with me wouldn't talk to me
anymore Jaya continues to talk so that's
that's part of an answer and here's the
other and there will be other examples
gems even Rama who is from a low caste
is a Dalit he was cabinet minister in
India's central government for 40 years
from 1940s to the 1980s till his death
and even Rams daughter is a
distinguished political figure now she
was Speaker of the of Indian Parliament
she's written at length judge even Rams
second wife much younger than him has
written of three volume or biography so
there is a lot of writing there which
once again celebrates the public figure
writes about how wonderful this figure
was how self-sacrificing how dedicated
to the nation that they would give up
home be in jail you know do all that
sort of work but in all of that writing
a lot comes through about judge even ROM
and about the women and what they had to
go through which wouldn't figure
anywhere Indian drums own writings so
there is a lot of stuff like that and
it's endless the the fact is that
impressions fictional writings there's
all kinds of other stuff the
generational divide is marked there very
very significant so this is just a
beginning when this is the kind of the
this the seed of what I think could be
well I hope you gonna bear with me it's
a Sparling question but I was struck
listening to your talk but it's almost
bringing to bear kind of the old
feminist adage of the personal is
political right these men have public
lives where they are advocating for
really the Equality of women
educationally satisfy this but it seems
like the overwhelming desire especially
with other feminists for kind of the
work of social reproduction not to cease
but to become invisible and for that to
kind of not count and I was really
thinking of kind of attention between
this vision of sort of aligned with the
mind intellectual work life dedicated to
the nation kind of being in direct
contrast to something like I miss our
friends work in the white pen donation
which is sort of about the centrality of
sort of producing these moderate wives
companion proper subjects that's kind of
the work of the nation and reproducing
the home in that way and where there
seemed to be more that I was really
curious about I'm hoping you'll just say
a little bit more is in the final kind
of suffereth an example there seems to
be a language of
attachment that's added to an attachment
to home attachment to sort of space
making it's limiting in some ways in his
kind of worldview I'm curious you just
expand on that a little bit and how
that's either in a productive attention
to these other things that people have
written about sort of kind of the
culture of nation being shaped through
the work of women and these kind of
individual ideas of sort of mobility and
you know I think I think you're right to
point in that direction the personal is
political is is spot-on
it is correct except that the personal
is political has not been asked about
the men and and therefore it's just an
entry point which is of significance and
it seems to me there's so much there a
it's just endless in which the only way
in which they can articulate themselves
the way they do they can retain the
narratives that they have is by denying
social physical reproduction and the
home you know it's there its background
and you know it's just you can see it's
so widely Hindu wife Hindu nation and
much of the writing makes the point
about companion companionate
relationships about the wife as the
producer of sons who will rebuild the
nation and produces that modular
statement about the woman and I really
do think that there's just lots more
going on here within these days homes
which is not taken on board it appears
in this thing
I think sankrityayan has the accident of
being this wonder and desiring the
wandering life from a very early age is
married at 11 from about the age of 13
his champing at the bit he really
doesn't want to be there he doesn't want
to be stuck I've been very struck you
know I said at the beginning that the
changes between that time and and
subsequent time
second half of the 20th 20th century are
dramatic it is astonishing how common
child marriage was and no one spoke
about it if the child marriage had for
some reason this you know collapsed or
whatever else there was a woman back
there
there was a wife back that hidden
completely nobody I've been now talking
to many many people and they appear
everywhere and it is just absolutely
common it is standard society we are
Graham was one kind of statement of what
was allowed that you know you had a
relationship with the wife which was the
required social practice required status
building but your romance was somewhere
else so that we've had some films about
we've had no films no reflection on the
fact and I I have I had teachers who
never admitted any of this to me
whom I know now had a child marriage and
left their wives completely at home and
wandered the world so this is the point
I think sank return because of the
accident of actually literally walking
so much and learning so much you know
inquiring feeling emboldened discovering
that there were worlds beyond what he
had imagined then produces this kind of
philosophical reflection on the life of
wandering and how it is superior to the
life of being stuck in one place my
suggestion and my hunch is that this is
what men in general have imbibed that
that sort of thing is where wisdom is
found is where our real work is even if
you don't do any damned work at all and
that the home is just background it just
happens to be there and we need it to
produce children and we need it to
recuperate and we need it for a variety
of other reasons but its background and
I think we really need to mark that
I also should say this is not just India
this is very widespread until of course
quite recent times in in North America
for example but it had the Indian
infliction is question mark right and
does have a burden which i think is
almost unparalleled it is extraordinary
and the self in self indoctrination the
fact that it is shared all the women
reproduces all the time and they feel
that is what we need to do there is no
other way of being good being right and
so there's a huge history written into
this what is modern India all about and
I think it begins to open it up
[Applause]
[Music]